Vala pana austerity finally some action
back door emergency on Whitney
that's me Ruby McGuire presidential
advisor say zucchini barchi Fianna fáil
the first freshman ever named captain of
the women's rugby team last year Fiona
took her team to the ship
she once bit off an opponent's ear and
scrum and ate it I tried to make the
owner part of my inner circle but with
limited success what are you drawing
the undercurrent Li has a used condoms
doctor toe I suspect this is the cause
of her distress
my condolences Fiona sexual contact in
public places is strictly verboten any
idea who could have used a sharp before
you probably the guy that's been
throwing bottles of piss in the trash
can
puppy bottle boy I'll destroy him Bobby
wouldn't set foot in women's bathroom
the real culprit is still out there but
you have my word justice will be served
what makes you think I need your help
because I just found a clue this flap of
dead skin belongs to the perpetrator
[Music]
Jeff Gillian and Jill Jeffries all-star
heavyweight rowers on the rare tunic
routine to simulate high-altitude
training this blunder couple sleeps in
an oxygen deprivation tent who are you
again Ruby your RA we've met several
times oh right sorry
doesn't matter what were you two doing
last night I was it practice I was
pulling an all-nighter at the Starbucks
Student Center has free coffee why not
there because I like their pumpkin spice
lattes any late-night nookie in the lava
Troy what no I'm on a three-month fast
until sprints that means no drinking no
smoking no sex don't even look at me we
should be talking buddy photo boy
probably dr. the burners down the hall
Vic and Val we definitely
[Music]
[Applause]
Valmet nor and Vic Valentine people say
they did love each other in every room
on campus where were you two last night
last night what were you two doing last
night
oh we were spinning at the glitterati
party anything leave a Jimmy in the
shower did we get busy in the shower
good way we could wait did you or did
you not in the shower
it's nothing how do you know that they
haven't showered in weeks
now smells like trench foot then I want
Bobby bottle boy Bobby Sokolov a
friendless germaphobe at the bottom of
the campus food chain rumor has it he
can only go TP and pass the bottle hey
Ruby hey friend do you mind if we come
in for a minute huh no it's not no your
good time what are you hiding in there
Bobby nothing by the looks of it the
kids been peeing in bottles for months
broken about three dozen health codes he
pees in bottles because he's a
germaphobe even though he pees and
bottles he's a decent man you're so
naive Ruby he's a sick freak this is the
grossest thing I've seen in my 15 years
campus security what's gonna happen to
him it's his third strike expulsion most
likely this is [ __ ] your college kid
Ruby not take a class take a cooki
elective learn a book leave the campus
security to the campus cops all right
[Music]
hi hi I just wanted to thank you for
helping me out you know I used to think
that residential advisors would just
bought upperclassmen but no friends but
you're not like that Ruby I brought you
some leftover holiday blues when to
start back stop serving PS else December
31st I figured it out have you I knew
something was fishy when I saw the
gender bear hand a condom like it ain't
no thing I suspected it was his from the
start
jewels alibis bunk she wasn't at
Starbucks last night pumpkin spice
lattes are seasonal beverage last night
Jill was at the glitterati party shaking
her tail feather with mole hunting over
here that's a lie
the same glitter in from wristbands from
the rave so things got sweaty and sticky
on the D floor and you couldn't go back
to Jill's room but I'm guessing you to
know he was moonlighting as an undergrad
this is only party I liked all night
every day she went to the women's
bathroom I work out for three hours a
day my hormones are going crazy I yeah
you're good this time you get a warning
two more of these and you'll go before
the Disciplinary Board this is why
everyone says that you're a loser
checkmate [ __ ] yeah
another whodunit solved an innocent man
walks free the guilty parties brought to
justice will this victory quiet the
voices that torture my restless spirit I
doubt it til next time
your college kid Ruby